Bonjour. Je suis Denis Villeneuve,
le réalisateur de Blade Runner 2049.
J'ai décidé de demander à des artistes que je
respecte de créer trois histoires courtes
qui mettent en scène des évènements majeurs
qui ont eu lieu après 2019,
l'année durant laquelle se déroule
le premier Blade Runner,
mais avant 2049, là où ma nouvelle histoire
de Blade Runner commence.
Mon ami Luke Scott a réalisé
le court-métrage que vous allez voir.
J'espère que vous apprécierez cet aperçu spécial
dans le monde de Blade Runner 2048.
Je veux juste vérifier
un vieux numéro de série.
D'avant le Black Out ?
Ça va être dur.
Bonjour.
- Salut.
- Comment tu vas ?
Ça va bien.
- Où est ta maman ?
- Elle est toujours là-bas.
- Alors, tu m'as ramené quoi cette fois ?
- J'ai...
"La Puissance et la Gloire".
Très passionnant.
Tu l'auras vite fini.
Ça parle d'un prêtre hors-la-loi qui....
qui essaie de comprendre
ce que c'est que d'être humain.
Ce n'est pas triste, j'espère ?
C'est l'un de mes préférés,
tu vas adorer.
- On se voit la prochaine fois.
- Bientôt.
Bon travail, Sapper.
Sérieusement...
Trois mille.
Trois mille ? Ça couvre à peine
le coût de la nématodiase.
À trois mille, je te fais une fleur.
Allez. Pour une fois...
Tu as déjà acheté mes blocs.
Riche en nutrients et peu d'impuretés,
ce sont les meilleurs, tu ne trouveras pas...
Allez.
Quatre mille.
Si t'aimes pas mon offre,
essaie ailleurs.
Toujours un plaisir
de faire affaire avec vous.
S'il vous plait, laissez-nous tranquilles !
Reste là ! On a à faire avec toi et ta maman !
- Laissez-moi !
- Bouge pas ! Bouge pas !
Ouais. Auberon 2 2 B.
Je crois avoir trouvé l'andro en cavale
que vous cherchiez.
J'ai son adresse.
À plus.
La première fois que j'ai vu Blade Runner,
j'en étais bouche bée.
La vision de Ridley Scott avait frappé
tant de cordes différentes,
je pouvais instantanément reconnaitre
son impact sur le monde cinématique tout entier.
À présent, on m'a offert la chance
incroyable de continuer l'histoire
en réalisant Blade Runner 2049,
qui reprend 30 ans après le premier film.
De cette façon, j'ai décidé de demander
à des artistes que je respecte
de créer trois histoires courtes
qui mettent en scène des évènements majeurs
ayant eu lieu après 2019,
l'année du premier Blade Runner,
mais avant 2049, lorsque ma nouvelle
histoire Blade Runner commence.
Mon ami Luke Scott a réalisé
le court-métrage que vous allez voir.
J'espère que vous apprécierez cet aperçu spécial
du monde de Blade Runner 2036.
Toutes nos banques de données de l'époque
ont été endommagées durant le Black Out.
Mais parfois des fragments demeurent.
Non...
Conclusion de la séance, 23h17.
Déposition de moi et Wallace
aux secteurs du Magistrat EL 1 et 9 à 26...
etc, terminé sans charge.
Merci pour votre patience.
Je n'avais pas l'intention
de vous faire patienter.
Les spécificités de mon handicap...
difficilitent les déplacements.
M. Wallace, nous vous avons accordé
cette réunion par égard à vos... contributions.
Vos contributions essentielles.
Nous l'avons reconnu
pour le bien de la population.
Pour leur bien-être.
Vous vous souvenez de la famine ?
Donc vous assouvissez l'hermite dont
les brevets gardent cette famine à distance ?
Je crois en la vie.
En fait, j'ai apporté plus de vie
à la Terre que jamais.
Mais elle se meurt.
Vous vous mourez.
Ce qui nous amène
à notre sujet actuel.
La prohibition.
Notre position sur le sujet est claire.
La prohibition sur les technologies de Réplicants
n'est pas ouverte au débat.
Et son abrogation non plus.
Et pourtant, nous faisons un débat.
Pas nous.
Tout ce qui a été perdu durant le Black Out,
cette "coupure dans l'Histoire", est mort et enterré.
L'humanité a toujours survécu jusqu'à présent
en refaçonnant la Terre pour répondre à ses besoins.
Les étoiles, notre seul espoir,
sont cachées derrière les vies
que vous refusez de me laisser créer.
Les colonies extérieures sont en pleine expansion.
Insuffisamment pour les besoins
de notre ultime survie.
Vos lois ont changé les mains du progrès.
Nos lois empêchent que la violence
déferle dans les rues.
Les Nexus sont dangereux.
Les mesures de sécurité
mises en place par Tyrell
sont défaillantes.
Trop de gens sont morts.
Nous ne permettrons pas d'autres victimes.
Mes Réplicants auront une vie aussi longue
ou aussi courte qu'un client le souhaitera.
Mes Réplicants ne se révolteront jamais.
Ils ne s'enfuiront jamais.
Ils ne feront qu'obéir.
Avance-toi.
Trouve une arme rapidement.
Nom de...
Qu'est-ce qu'il se passe ?
Ceci...
est un ange.
Et c'est moi qui l'ai fabriqué.
Regarde vers le haut à gauche,
montre-leur.
Vous êtes en train de
commettre un crime, Wallace.
Ça suffit maintenant.
Soulève le verre.
Coupe.
C'est immoral.
Est-ce que cela fait mal ?
Oui.
Tu dois faire un choix.
Ta vie ou la mienne.
Tu comprends ?
Oui.
Fais-le tout de suite.
C'est immoral...
Les actes des humains
résonnent dans les cieux.
L'écho de la cloche se fait entendre.
Ce que nous décidons ici aujourd'hui...
embellira ou brisera le firmament.
Qu'en sera-t-il ?